2012 the Hubble Space Telescope makes a
gruesome discovery it finds killer stars
sucking the life from their neighbors
these vampire killers are found lurking
inside tightly packed groups of stars
known as clusters stars are born in
giant clouds of dust and gas and these
clouds have enough material to make
dozens or even hundreds of stars we call
these family of stars star clusters and
we think they're all roughly the same
age young clusters shine like jewels
with an array of bright colors blues
yellows and reds
but this starry rainbow changes over
time the blue stars disappear first
these are the biggest stars in the
cluster burning brightly and dying young
after millions of years next to go are
the yellow stars these medium-sized
stars aged over billions of years
gradually turning red like ripening
fruit after 10 billion years the entire
cluster matures to a deep red this
gradual shift in color is useful to
astronomers because it allows them to
judge how old a cluster is but in the
1950s astronomers spotted something
seriously weird in an ancient cluster
tucked amongst the old red stars they
found a handful of brightly shining
young blue stars new stars don't usually
form inside mature clusters so how did
they get there the only explanation
somehow the old stars were getting
younger
astronomers dubbed these age defying
stars blue stragglers
if you imagine these blue stragglers
chars were people in a crowd these stars
would look like they had been given a
facelift they're masquerading as younger
stars when really they're just as old as
everybody else in the room in 2015
Natalie took a closer look at the Hubble
images of the blue straggler cluster she
discovered that most of the young
looking stars weren't binary
partnerships with the corpses of dead
stars that appear to have had their gas
sucked away from them so in movies
vampires are perpetually youthful
because they are sucking blood from
humans and so in this case we have stars
that are sucking gas and material from
other stars keeping them looking young
gas is the fuel that allows all stars to
burn and with new gas stars revitalized
you